hi everyone I've a lot and I have
another giveaway for you guys such a
nice guy modest too but for reals i have
a xbox one copy of destiny to give away
for one lucky one and it will arrive on
sep tember night so you'll be getting it
on launch day this one is only open to
australian and new zealand resident so
the giveaway is actually on my Facebook
page people just don't seem to reply to
youtube messages anymore and I find
people will often reply to the facebook
messages so the link to my facebook is
below so that you can check out the
details but to get you thinking the
question is going to be in 25 words or
less which class is super ability would
you use and why I mean in like everyday
life as well not in actual destiny so
like when you go to the shops which one
would help you out the most artists
creative answer will win and I will have
to finish up the competition on at the
7th thank you very much Activision for
giving me the opportunity to let some of
my fans play destiny with me but so that
this video isn't just me talking about a
giveaway I have also included some of my
time playing the destiny beta I hope you
guys enjoy it so here we are and press
that to see my current objective so this
is ghost voiced by Peter Dinklage who is
well known as being Tyrion and Game of
Thrones and I am on this pretty city
here some other fellow running over
there not entirely sure what i'm doing
but there are people shooting so what's
that red on the top there oh oh hello hi
there
well just like a bus right behind name I
love that the mailing is very very cool
okay some of them a tougher than others
but you notice to me they all just look
entirely like something from a look like
this would be unfair maybe probably not
a grunt but drugs basically acts the
same as grunts really low on health and
everything and yeah nothing nothing too
exciting there honestly don't know where
I'm going right now I seem all right
over you so let's just see if this
thing's pretty range oh wow it is solid
okay what's that
feel like this is you know this is an
MMO but there's no one with me right now
no it my help um it feels very barren
and I wonder if that's because it's a
beta but I don't know I've never really
felt inclined to bloody up with anyone
for any amount of time really it just
said just 40 no I don't know that it
just feels weird playing an MMO without
a keyboard to be honest you can't really
communicate with people that easily and
it just doesn't really feel necessary
where are we going here oh hello Shh
can't change weapons is what I'm
thinking another one yeah I think this
is like a shotgun but I feel like I'm
the way the weapons change so slower
like takes forever maybe that's
something here upgrade eventually but
this point just annoying yeah shut gun
where else well they want that it looks
like that might be it
you can jump as well I'm running right
now obviously some more people to shoot
at is that a friend no yeah handles are
a little bit stronger than drugs and
they also kind of mealy back sometimes
the damn good at it so I guess they are
the elites of destiny I mean what it's
totally not halo I just I do think this
is really pretty especially for it Emma
Bonino cuz like all of the ones that
I've played on pc just so unattractive
because they have to be to sort of
understand everything worse this works
really well I also do like how you know
when you're not involved in combat its
third person I find that really
effective too alright so this quickly
becomes repetitive um just a lot of a
lot of shootie business really but there
is you know there is a story here um
it's just I kind of like that it's so
basic because if it makes you try and
focus on the fun more than actually
football or Eva Drake a more than
actually focusing on you know the story
of it which like halo sometimes kind of
feels like it falls as a story on you
it's like yeah this is obviously just an
FPS doesn't matter that much but then
it's like oh wait pay attention to our
story we've carefully crafted it but
really they haven't deployed garst sure
thing buddy
go do things to that the shift avionics
are completely catatonic but i can't
call their last transmission
they managed to restore an information
up here down in the tunnels below we
should check it out I will see you guys
on my Facebook page on Alana and thanks
for watching bye bye